[Music]
it's safe to say that
if you're even remotely serious about
counter-strike you're playing in an
aspect ratio that's
well wide
whether you're repping 16-10 or
even 5-4 you know that you can't call
yourself an
edgy csgo e-gamer unless you're
stretching that screen resolution i play
in-game is 11 52
by 864
and i play stretcher the resolution i'm
playing in csgo right now is
1280 versus 960 i'm using the stration
i use 128 for 960.
oh no stretch it and when you think
about it
why wouldn't you give your resolution a
good old tug bigger bodies
better spray control crispier movement
and a cleaner more succinct crosshair
gap
but what initially started as a
haphazard way to squeeze
frames out of a crummy pc has since
become a standard
one that virtually every mid to high
level head popper in the whole of global
offensive
follows when i play league or i play war
zone or whatever it is
even world of warcraft you know i play
full hd i don't really care about it
but somehow the myth stays in
cs go where everyone uses for free
and if you don't use for free you're
made fun of in fact
over the course of global offensive's
decade-long lifespan
there have been a very few
self-respecting
tier one pros who've even entertained
the idea of running 16.9
that is unless you're csgo's native
son i introduce to you the skull popping
prodigy
robin rops cool a supremely talented
estonian rifler
whose incredible journey from proclaimed
cheater
to world-class talent taught him that if
he was gonna make his mark on the game
he loved
he'd need to do it on his own terms
a bomb plant is available to rops at a
bare minimum and that's something for
mouse sports to work with he's retrieved
an m4
i don't think it's got any ammo left in
it so he's got to get this done with the
deagle and he does find the first man in
he's
statistically in nice reactions the two
kills rops has found so far
i think he's fired three bullets and
there's a fourth oh my god he is looking
robotic he's grateful executes another
you see in addition to his stellar
rifling dank ass deagling
and just generally being one of the best
counter-strike competitors alive
robs is known for something else
something
odd something that shouldn't be weird
but for better or for worse is
he runs his game in the resolution
in which it was meant to be played it's
fun to be uh
this guy that is only using 16x9 in the
world
in top level cs i'm not sure if i am the
only one there might be
some more but i've actually never looked
into it but if i if i
really am then i mean yeah it's it's fun
it's memes
gives you some some pretty random
exposure at times like
like this okay so what is this weird
obsession with
stretched was it by chance or design
that rops became
the poster boy of 69 and what might his
deviation from the norm
spell for future generations of
counter-strike enthusiasts
get some fresh meat out of it robs is
gonna be that worse to
found third and fourth spray control
perfection
and ace in a matter of seconds
okay so first things first what in the
hell
are stretched resolutions and how did
the cs community become
certifiably obsessed with them well you
may not know this but as with a lot of
things in global offensive
stretched actually got its start because
of
get right you see back when cs go first
came out
it was common for professional players
to play in 4-3
since it made the game feel more like
1.6
and because it offered the one thing
that all
cs players crave
frames the problem is that when you play
in a reduced resolution
you get black bars so in an effort to
make
full use of his monitor get right full
screened it
i remember me and friday were sitting on
a tournament called eswc back then
the monitors back then was like 75 hertz
on the tournament
uh it wasn't used to stand at like 120
or 2040 like it is nowadays
i remember i actually i played with
stretch time to time in 1.6
i talked to fryer a lot with it and i
think me and him
change directly to stretch on that one
because it felt more smoother and it
felt like
you have more control when you're moving
around and where you can spray around
with it
now in addition to making the game feel
better get right discovered that
in some ways it also made it easier to
play
but then i also noticed more and more it
felt like that the models itself became
more
fatter in a way or like more dragged out
i feel like you can hit them more easier
and you can actually feel the sprays
itself it was like
actually hitting more and more now it's
no secret that in the early days of cs
go
get right and nip were literal
juggernauts
and after going on an 87-0 map run on
lan
people began to take notice of what the
steamrolling swedes were doing
differently
so in an effort to beat the best they
did the
one thing that to this day is
scientifically
guaranteed to make you as good as the
pros
copy their config
settings simple settings
simple settings copying pro settings
really do make you better chat
i am literally living proof that if you
copy somebody else's settings one for
one
you can be whatever you want to be i am
now simple
anyway before long stretched had
cemented itself as the go-to aspect
ratio for
sweaty tryhards everywhere sure it
warped the game beyond recognition and
yes it made your skins look like
ass but if you were a real one it didn't
matter
since as far as anyone could tell it
offered a competitive advantage
before long people were scavenging
youtube for tutorials such as nick
bunions
on the advantages of stretched how to
run it
and whether it actually made you a
better player this is
nine this is four three this is 1920 by
1080
this is 1280 by 960. if we zoom on the
1080p
and we put a pink box around the
character model and then we go to the
stretch then we put a green box around
the character model and then we
morph these photos we'll notice that
there is a bit of an advantage to having
it stretched because you are shooting at
a slightly
fatter target and sure there were a
handful of holdouts
but they were few and far between when
compared to the sea of screen stretching
superstars
who had demonstrated its superiority by
reaching
incredible heights hell it even wormed
its way into other
shooters like siege and yes even
fortnite
but as with all rules there had to be an
exception
and this one came out of nowhere later
on
i called sierra you know simple and
auras
but it's pretty cool is so many
professional lives i still use
and taking it on except props
okay so if you know anything about
counter-strike you've at least
heard of robs whose rise through face it
pro league was so
sudden and unprecedented that it incited
not only the ire of established prose
but a flurry of actual cheating
allegations
obviously like um all the cheating
allegations and stuff like that
those were pretty rough on me because i
those are the people i i
tried to look up to and i tried to
become one of them and then they
kind of went against me but in spite of
the abuse he suffered from some of his
peers
rops chose to silence them by taking his
online ass whoopings and
bringing them over to lan the mobile
tough comes back
and that's going to keep him at bay as
now the defuse is trying to be stuck
here they re-tap it again
a flash once more and robs the peaks
drops them both and mousesports win the
round we're meant to be robson
should find a few frags here there's
three that's quite nice
and the ace taking two of his own and
it's looking quite smooth here
deagle though from rops and all of a
sudden
this becomes doable ak collected easy
frag they're catching rain as he jumps
up
now it's just down to aloo ah the flick
from rops there
great clutch four frags for him in the
round now in addition to
rising above his detractors and
overcoming
tremendous personal loss as soon as ross
took to the world stage in 2017
he became pretty much the only truly
top-level competitor in
all of cs go to play in 16
9. so how did he start using 69 in the
first place
well i'll tell you this it wasn't
because he was some
scrub who didn't know any better you see
in spite of his young age
rops was a true oh gee one point sixer
like he thought cs go was for zoomers
i didn't even know it's csgo was a thing
until like 2014 because um
i i stopped playing 1.6 like when it
died out like around 2012.
it was a holly in the start at night i i
didn't really play uh
anything serious even in 1.6 but it's
like puff servers
yeah back then rops like everyone was
playing 4-3 stretched because of
hardware limitations but once he
upgraded his rig
he became a true 16x9 boy
what's interesting about all of this is
that it isn't just cosmetic
yes 69 does make your skins look better
but just as one tappers and wandeegers
swear that
stretched gives them that added
advantage rops his proclivity towards
native
both suits and enables his anchory
playstyle
69 feels a little bit slower and i think
that suits
rob's playing style because he's it's
not a hardcore lurker
it's more a methodical and like really
looking to the opening i always find the
right spots to help his team out
personally if you ask me why would i
pick 16 by nine then
i think it's just logic because why
would you
pick a resolution that's small but the
other one
is literally giving you more field of
view i have like a situation every day
my
in my practice maybe that's i see a guy
that my teammate doesn't
you know it's very often these things
happen oh they synced up the glass break
that's hot that's actually wild isn't
there that's so
good and look what it's led to robs has
no idea
is going to be kicking himself palm to
face
but i think it's pretty cool that he
goes against the trend use something
that
suits him and how he got learned the
game by
himself instead of like looking on
youtube and seeing hey
well sierra is the best player in 2016.
let's use his resolution and
let's use his settings sensitivity
crosstalk everything he just go by it
and then becomes like one of the best
players in the world
robs uses his own stuff here's the
really cool thing though
in the years since rob's unexpected rise
he's inspired others at the top level to
question
whether 4-3 is for them the models get
bigger so like
unless you play like some ridiculously
low sensitivity and have insane aim and
like insane cross replacement like rops
i think uh
the models being bigger is just easy to
shoot right it would be cool if you can
go
back and force yourself to play on a
like a higher resolution because
there's so many incidents where people
have missed so many enemies
because you used like four free
resolution bondic might get caught no
man's land here
because he's pushing out with no cover
and al who's just hiding behind the rock
he'll spot him does he see him does he
see him four by three
four by three there's no way he didn't
see him on the right side
ultimately rob's resolution isn't just a
reflection of who he is as a player
it's also indicative of who he is as a
person
but it works for him and that's the
beauty of his skill and how he raced to
the top where
he already got accused by shooting in
the beginning everyone thought he would
never get a chance in the professional
scene
he got invited to miles what shows off
directly that he can perform on land
and perform against the top levels and
he uses a resolution that no one answers
it just blows my mind away and i think a
lot of people likes that with him
because he sticks out
with everything it does now does that
mean we're in for some kind of
resolution revolution
probably not that being said we are
starting to see
more players experiment with 16 9 as
well as a few
full-blown converts who are hitting
shots that just wouldn't be possible
otherwise
just twist have a kit yes he does and a
scout
with pcs getting more powerful by the
day and games like valorant
literally making it so stretched isn't
viable
it's hard to know what the future holds
for esports's various native gangs
what we do know is that when all is said
and done
your resolution is yours to decide
whether you stand stretched have some
weird obsession
with black bars fancy yourself a good
old
69 boy or just want to [ __ ] your [ __ ] up
take a page out of rops's notebook and
just
do you if you want to stand out don't
conform to the trend
bucket that's how you become great why
did everyone use this for free stretch
in the beginning
well it was because i forced it into
everyone or
he and some others did force it into
everyone else to use it because
those were the best players or the
players everyone looked up to
so i was a trendsetter with some else in
the beginning
now robs is the trendsetter using 69.
and
look at the end of the day if a no-good
normy ass aspect ratio was good enough
for an
fpler to become a top 10 player
in the world it's good enough for anyone
there's no real advantage obviously to
any resolution i think
except for the fact that if you play 4x3
you have less field of vision
thus that's a fact but i i i said
outside of that fact i feel i still
think it's like it's just a
personal choice and i don't think you
need to have a stretch resolution to
become a pro
the truth is that there are no god
rezzes
only gods and robs well
no matter what he's playing on he's one
of them
oh my god
[Music]
you need to win okay
easy i feel like we may rule this
right in the world
in the world in the world
it's good enough for anyone